who is the boring claim mark oh can you
do skins customize your colors keep cus
I don't want to live all right how do I
do it okay
all right guys yes yes yes you're the
same [ __ ] clay man no I'm not
Wow yeah see we buff you not see me got
a thing happen to your mouth I got a
smirk what is this game what what's the
point
we're like platforming it's a puzzle
platformer with gang beasts controls all
right why wait why I'm going to show you
what death is I already see what death
is
I'm going around oh yeah I try to do
things I try to do things and you just
ruin it you ruin it dad
hey you down there you might be dead you
might be dead you're I'd be careful down
there and we want to die if I were you
be careful
you would never be careful you you've
never known careful in your life you
guys are doing a great job yeah I'm
getting there hang on
yeah there's got to be a way right hang
on I have a better plan I'm not gonna
walk claw well hey Mark if you die it's
fawn over ears then you don't learn you
don't learn you see you not learning me
I'm a learner
you're really getting closer man I think
you're getting there hey wait do you
want to go do the rest of this you owe
me a life-debt Wade you gotta get me a
pet I think
you oh wait there was literally a way to
just drag you off and make you not be
alive anymore you gotta come get me you
guys when you're playing video games
mark just mind like yours listen you
can't talk about you on the island mr.
frog on a log in a bargain smart yep you
oh you guys just going together I was
gonna all right pee fountain thank you
Bob listen I'm beginning to think that
these game developers don't have any
sort of maturity their mark you might
say Baba saved your life
life dead life dead oh hey we both owe
way to life that now mark I know I don't
remember that Wade you need to I will
take two burritos extra chicken and
that'll pay your life dead to me come on
mark let's what are we doing here I
don't go forward today yeah absolutely
listen guys what do you think you think
this is 2016 where you can just get in
the game and be antics now we need
philosophical discussions of why we're
here
that is train that is death what is
between is our existence there you go
that makes sense do you think that we as
characters died when that train smashed
through the station that we're in a
purgatory forever I got this with my
expert climbing ability that I've
learned and earned rawr XD yeah Tom stop
Rex dee stop the car stop making it I'm
gonna
make this rawr daddy here we go Oh
actually okay okay rawr I'm gonna really
need you to stop doing that rawr why you
want to owe me a life-debt housetop no
really really terrible oh oh hey wait am
i to the place you guys have been trying
to get to this whole time I think you
skipped straight through all the way
yeah I think I did actually I think I
did I want to talk to you who's about to
skip all the way to the end it's me
right that's I'm gonna [ __ ] my pants
which is a reaction I both appreciate
there's a physiological reaction that I
wasn't expecting but you know I
appreciate my ability to do it I think
what I'm trying is the way I don't think
I'm doing it right with I'm doing
through the one door that you guys
already made there I'm the best oh we
don't need the puzzles I've played
through this before I've done all this
19 2016 where's the new [ __ ] Bob hadn't
played so I started from the beginning
he's clearly played everything played
this this is my first time ever playing
this he has a custom skin wait why would
this be the first time oh wait do you
didn't think this through
I made this custom skin while we were
waiting for you to come back no no no no
no yeah you've lied to me before so I
don't trust Oh you can do zombies stand
ups that's fun what does that mean
wouldn't you like to know person who's
still trying to get over to where we are
at
so says the man who's never played this
game before
I didn't tell me I trust him I did it
I'm going around I've made it wow that's
a heck of a move I know right
excuse me excuse me excuse me rawr XD
where'd you go all thank God you ended
it Oh No Oh see I got the achievement
choo choo alright alright here's this
puzzle we take this bomb going all right
mark how you getting into hanging around
this mess huh easily handily with my
hands how long if I hit him with this
box yeah that would be pretty funny I
think mark grab this box we'll save you
here mark we're totally totally got you
but don't worry about it grab my [ __ ]
rawr give me that get it we'll pull you
up dude I can't reach it
lower lower wait bring me the box ooh
woo thank you wait wait wait wait wait
let me grab I don't have it yet okay all
right I got to throw both of you and the
box off the which only seems fair damn
it I'm over here now
I made it what am i doing what how did
you do that oh you just like this nope
all right I'll just do all this in the
style of my mentor and role model fine
if you want to solve the puzzle like me
like I do say so I had this my way
actually happened is this where you went
mark what where I don't know where you
are so oh my god wait wait come back hey
hang on hey buddy listen I'm trying to
go up take me with you
hey Mark hey I'm good wait no no I got
this I got this give me give me one
chance give me one chance to do this and
I'll show you that I can finish it
without using that leap leap leap
oh no no no no hey Mark you might grab
me by the head and pull me nope
let's do it mark I'm doing this there
wait I'll save you all right come on
what the hell all right now now I'll
save you what the hell
God oh this game I had fun mark yeah I
am having lots of fun at the most fun
anybody's ever had in this game there we
go some kind of troubles there oh yeah
yeah well didn't you open up yo I go
without making silly sounds yo I'm gonna
make sure your sounds just grabbed say
yes should have made silly sounds I
should have committed to the bit [ __ ]
didn't didn't heal to go backwards I did
for some reason I your made it I'm now
officially better than Bob by a country
mile nigut I'm as bad as Mark times - no
no look at me
you couldn't be hmm from the cookie jar
if the only point of this level to teach
you how to jump and grab
there's alligator what the hell I'm not
grabbing my guys not grabbing you so
lazy what a lazy cuz they're gonna jump
on the train this is unfortunate
no I'm learning no there's no way that I
could make that jump yeah Marc I don't
know how you get on top of here who
needs to go on top of here when you can
go around maybe it's happening and
there's not a damn thing you can do to
stop it whoo whoo I've beaten the system
huh yeah what do you got hiding in those
pants of yours I rawr I got some of the
extra toasty cheez-its I was saving from
all did you really do you really have to
solve all the puzzles without me is that
necessary wait okay wait I'm over here
up on top of the Train and jump over is
that working out for you
he's gonna get all the way around just
to find out he has to climb up and jump
over and I'll grab your ankles jump if I
just jump if I jump I jump yeah I'm
holding Wade out for you
[Laughter]
I think mark has the right idea think
marks dead-on take marks I'm gonna try
and do the jump the big job I think
that's the way to do it all right so
let's bring the train back please I
didn't know we moved it you complete all
right okay interesting interesting very
interesting but I see a separate
solution all right mark you ready I've
already got it not I don't believe you
do pretty good no you do not I got this
there we go it's as easy as American Pie
this game is actually really fun well
all right do you guys know this game is
fun got you ill defined concept
grumbling wait like several life-debt
sorry Bob I'll uh I'll just hang out
right here oh did you want me to give
you a hand climbing up is that what you
were looking at me grab me my head what
about mine I'll let go of your hands
there we go that's big and bulbous it is
oh okay I didn't have you quite yet
apparently I think I got you okay I
trust Oh help me out no you waste so
much coming all right I'm gonna
there we go you're gonna fling me off
the side oh my god this doesn't feel
this feels suspicious
I don't think about this better go
around there's a rock there yeah you can
go around go I got it
oh you can't go this is very not safe in
here Marty I didn't say it wasn't safe I
said it was suspicious sorry I delayed
reaction
oh you landed on some cookies yeah all
right so how do we rip these planks off
of here just missed my jump oh here mark
I got some wood for you there you go
I got plenty of wood mines yeah mark is
this helpful to you do you need these
maybe who knows who is the smash what's
the smash those your your calling was to
smash all right Bobby did it get it is
what I do every day I'm getting it wrong
nice work
thank you get it mark thank you I am
around I've done it where am I kudos so
close I think I smashed adequately yeah
I give up I thought I was gonna make oh
I'm here oh I'm still here ooh
interesting interesting interesting this
is very interesting guys guys I am very
far ahead of you my spine is broken why
does it take a while overheard the
character to get up every once in a
while yep all right mark you're not you
literally spawn in the room we're in huh
where are you what do you mean we're
right over on the other side of this
wall now I'm at the construction site
have I won did I win guys I think I've
won you ever feel like we have to
accomplish something so that we can move
on from our meaningless existence is
here Bob and I are smashing all your
climbing yeah Wade and I are smashing
all up on each other
kind of a dumpster it looks like it goes
in here okay well that's not what I
would call it but you put a word on it I
rode the dumpster down and I got the dog
Oh was I not supposed to do that oh my
god did I just screw up something stupid
because I wouldn't surprise me swing me
daddy-o which were supposed to be
swinging you what are you guys doing
Oh smashing I'm not supposed to be on
there oh there you guys are okay I'm
about to do a maneuver I'm above you
both in life why are you sorry excuse me
you're breaking up there I'm above yeah
sounds like you're just like telling
yourself I am I'm good I am up here by
the blue pipes do you see me yeah I see
you now okay is there a wide swing this
gap can I swing this gap this might just
result in me falling but I think I can
swing this gap what I don't think I
timed it right now I'm in the rubble
interesting okay I didn't grab anything
that's all right well here's the ramp so
uh ramps are for nerds pipes your words
that join the pipe Club that box for us
no puck Club
what was that so that's work being done
while you're up there on your monkey
bars look it's a pipe not a monkey bar
you should know the difference we're
doing cool guy Club I don't even know
what you guys are doing you you're just
following what the man wants you to do
look I I'm a rebel I'm uh I'm uh I'm a
trendsetter um
I'm get up there yeah hope I Club no do
drop me puck oh yeah I'm on the puck
club ha
well that's not great anyway we have we
have lightweight it won't open
hold on hold on wait come here no
there's a better way
what am i here now hi what's up douche
bag douche bag you're the bag
are you using our ramp and so just climb
at the wall no pipe clubs it sure looks
like you are my god wait swing it back
towards me I made it I want to be cool
like you
you need this his box I will bring it to
you to move the thing the other way the
solution Hey look who's the cool guy
over here and wait wait I have an idea
okay I didn't mean I thought it was
touching I didn't mean to do that
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right okay okay I'm the hero here
I've got this but you decided to walk
straight off you moved it no you moved
it on me
you moved you're just trying to screw
over my okay
oh you're sneaky traps okay I made
through guys made through good job bud
thanks man too much I got you open - oh
Jesus Christ
well thanks for that I don't know what
do you do take a rock and break this
wall nerd wait what's this oh my god
actually works there's something over
here wait guys guys you're fools that's
a club but Club yeah I'll spawn mark
where are you I'm climbing
a lot of noise a lot of noise wait why
am i up here wait what is what is this
dude what does the pad do what pad pad
the orange pads what do the orange pads
do they're for safety or are they first
stacking so you can I think there's
something in here that we need I am
going to find it have a lot of typically
guys found a pipe Club guys I found a
pipe Club opportunity Oh what is this oh
my god mark how did he walk on top of
these blue pipes I didn't do much of it
oh my god guys guys
oh dang it don't mind me just doing
things the old-fashioned way before
before there's a pipe Club dude you got
to join the pipe club my bub
oh my god I'm in a secret area guys guys
can you see me wherever you are
wait turn around no obviously not whoa
crazy bro oh wait I know the way okay
all right oh yeah all right this is
going to be tricky because it seems like
I could fall off at any moment Oh God
oh you got Bob Bob I'm about to join
your pipe huh not a great club
[Applause]
wait how are you doing that your your
actual wizard whoa hey Marty you need a
hand
try come up here man come on man let's
go to the pipe club guys you had some
sweet pipes going on why are you so
thumpy thumpy cuz I'm grumpy oh my god
it's so hard to do this you do this way
I've given up guys I give up I give up
hey Mark how's flying on cloud 9 of pipe
Club living the pipe Club dream I just
yeah we just swung away oh what's the
point Bob what's the point what's even
the point mark use your ass to break the
glass under you and you know so what's
the point so I'm gonna pull this lever
for me I guess well there's a lot easier
now that I didn't have Bob counteracting
every s'long oh my god you're actually a
wizard pipe club dreams are back baby
wait look where I am look where you are
you're so sad
everything about you oh god I win don't
know wait don't take this for me why
would you take hey could you at least
land it on the glass there well I'll be
doing good work keep it up Thanks you
know you know what mark you know what
work
listen hey listen come down here
[Applause]
[Music]
how do you crouch there we go
listen to me you listen you need to get
Beauty to puck up you need to get that
smirk off your face you need to get
serious and dreams are for children and
we are men playing a men's game in a
man's world wait I had it no I know I
know
wait I know but I earned this one more
can you do it can you love her me why
can't we break this glass I guess it's
fine it's open what are you doing to me
okay unit mark yeah yeah you know it
baby
you know it baby okay guys oh my god
guys how are you doing that what are you
doing it's rar XD time to do it for us
this is for us whoo whoo no wait don't
please don't do this for me no wait I
swear to god you're so close
[Laughter]
[Music]